it's been a prolonged drought in Somalia
some of its regions haven't seen rain in
two years
desperate for food water and grazing for
their cattle thousands of people are
fleeing their homes walking long
distances under the scorching Sun
Muhammad Ahmad and his family left their
coastal city
the 60 year old says he had to walk more
than a thousand kilometers to get to
this desolate Camp hoping to get food
and shelter
if you walk some distance out of here
you will see lots of Bones lots of
animal bones piled up on the top of each
other from all the corners the side of
these bones will shock you not only here
but throughout the region
Somalia is one of the poorest countries
in the world battered by Decades of
violence war and political instability
this drought could be its worst yet
the Yuan fears the crisis could be
similar to the 2011 famine which killed
more than a quarter of a million people
half of them children
thousands have died so far malnutrition
is killing children every day
four days ago and came while the chair
was not even a lot
the child was not even a lot was a bit
unconscious when the child caring but we
resuscitated started on put on
medication and that's why today at least
we consists that we can not some
improvement
the situation is critical Aid workers
sometimes take the limited resources
from the hungry to treat those who are
starving somalis blame the Russian
invasion of Ukraine for depleting
International Aid they used to receive
every year and for soaring food prices
the war between Ukraine and Russia has
worsened the serration of oil and wheat
which are not available we bring the
food all the way from Mogadishu and the
prices have skyrocketed since our land
is dry and unproductive the most
desperate Live in Central and Southern
parts of Somalia under the control of a
shabab the U.N blames the armed group
for contributing to the 2011 famine by
deliberately blocking or burning Aid
deliveries and targeting eight workers
for the time being and until Aid arrives
hundreds of thousands will have to deal
on their own with cholera my nutrition
and starvation